all right so the Kang gang is in full
force in quantumania and the MCU right
now but Kang's Origins just got a bit
more uh sticky let's say in the latest
run of the character Kang the Conqueror
only myself left to conquer so in this
video I want to talk about his newer
origin story how things differ here or
there and how this could influence the
upcoming phase six movie Avengers Kang
Dynasty obviously there are going to be
heavy spoilers for the Kang comic run so
this is your warning up front now that
I've given you some time to get out of
here get ready for the Kang bang but
yeah I'm your host Jared the he who
remains of heavy spoilers now let's get
into only myself left to conquer so
jumping into things Kings Origins have
somewhat been established in the halls
of time because uh he he is the master
of time born on Earth 6 3-1-1 in the
30th Century Nathaniel Richards studied
Robotics and cross-dimensional
recordings of Earth 616 after
discovering part of a time machine left
by his namesake and ancestor from Earth
616 he would eventually become king the
Conqueror who sought to become an
Overlord of the time space continuum and
his various super-powered variants now
here in Kang the Conqueror only myself
left to conquer Kang or Nathaniel
Richards Origins are a bit different
cherry-picking here or there from the
origins that were established earlier it
starts with Nathaniel Richards at 18
years old in a futuristic Utopia of the
31st Century the perfect world no famine
no war just sitting there watching
adults do Tick-Tock Dances all day long
but Richard's dreams of something bigger
he wants to actually do something with
his life as he sees the future doesn't
have anything interesting in store he
believes that the path is where the
excitement awaits basically Nostalgia as
he wants to actually feel something
searching for answers in Victor Von
Doom's old library he is attacked by a
doombot only to be swiftly saved by a
mysterious figure the international Man
of Mystery tells young Richards that
he'll only learn of one side of history
from the dusty old books revealing
himself as the Conqueror the Eternal the
god Pharaoh Rama tut the bad Tipper The
Time Keeper immortus I was once you but
I am now Kang offering him unlimited
power worlds and knowledge to explore as
young Richards joins him into the time
stream Kang takes the two to 65 Million
BC telling Richards he has but one year
to master his abilities and become who
Kang is now further elaborating he has
seen and done almost everything become
an ancient ruler facing off with the
fantastic IV The Avengers in Manhattan
Dr Doom trickery and much much more but
one moment stuck out to Young Richards
as Kang drank he cried in the shadows
once the name ravona was muttered Kang
told Richards their only weakness was
love never love don't do it maybe some
self-love here or there whenever you
need a release but never love another
Kang is a prisoner of himself his
defeats and failures so he needs to make
Richards perfect but is there really any
living in that sense Richards meets a
mysterious woman while out training
saving her life and then experiences the
joys of life from her Village as they
Feast eat drink dance and bond with one
another this is where they will live in
the space between the Stars Richards
rushes back to tell Kang all about
everything only for him to repeat the
quote the space between the Stars Kang
berates and abuses Richards for saying
he finally found something that he loves
in this world going against the one
thing that Kang said not to do as Kang
wipes out the village as Richard watches
in horror Richards realizes he had left
his cage of a mundane future but landed
in a completely different cage he
devises a plan to steal Kang's suit on
the final night before the final day
that the great asteroid would smash into
Earth jumping into the time stream
escaping the cage he was in exploring
the Limitless bounds of time and space
but he didn't know one thing was Rama's
Tut's cage was waiting for him the young
Nathaniel Richards finds himself at the
beginning of what is later called the
Kang Dynasty there it is there it is
obviously this is on the MCU docket for
phase six a I'll talk about it later in
the video don't worry but only myself
left to conquer would make for a rad
Kang story live action that is anyway
back to it Richards is saved by Moon
Knight crazy I know as the pair go to
meet with konshu though a twist of fate
it would be that Khan shu's current
vessel and the Moon Knight mantle
belongs to ravona the name the older
Kang would mention in passing and having
a very similar physique to the woman
Richards met back in 65 Million BC
believing this is a second chance
Richards wants to become the hero that
the other ravona from 65 Million BC saw
him as allowing Kang's neurokinetic
armor to morph into something a little
bit more hero-like iron lad he and
ravona fought off Legions of Rama Tut's
forces developing an affection for one
another again Richard's not listening to
the do not love advice of Kang and
kisses ravona but as they get to pecking
Rama Tut gets to reckon they're good
time enslaving rivona using his Ultra
diode Ray Richards his order to be
executed but advises Rama Tut this may
not be the best idea because if he is
him and him is he what would happen if
he killed thee and what would happen if
you hit that like And subscribe button
probably great things for the both of us
here smart thinking on both sides as
Rama taught enslaves Richards
transforming him into the leader of his
army the Scarlet Centurion however
things go awry as Rama's forces attempt
to go toe-to-toe with another mutant
force of ancient Egypt in sabaner or
rather apocalypse Richards now Scarlet
Centurion first learned of War during
this time the Rage of battle coursed
through his veins but soon realized his
body was a prison in armor a cage in
order to escape King power he needed
both to be broken and revenge was sworn
soon after ramata cowardly escaped back
into the time stream to avoid the
Fantastic Four Richards pledged
allegiance to Apocalypse Now reciting in
kanchu's Old Temple so the two could
destroy Kang their plan was essentially
to send Richards into the future with
apocalypse locking him in a sarcophagus
until it was time time to destroy Kang
and end this forever curse this brought
him into the modern times as The
Avengers were gearing up to fight Kang
arriving in his giant time ship as Thor
Iron Man Captain America wasp and giant
man were distracting Kang Richards snuck
aboard his way onto Kang's ship ready to
end it all attempting to escape back
into the time stream away from The
Avengers Richards pulls a blaster on
Kang telling him his entire plan ending
his life there taking the ship back to
Egypt and living his days out with
ravona but all of a sudden Dr Doom pops
out of nowhere from a Time stream
wanting to end Kang then and there
unfortunately Richards has to team up
with his enemy Kang to send Doctor Doom
soaring back into the Nexus which kind
of looks like the castle that he who
remains is partying in from the Loki
season finale just just look at this
Richard sticks to it shooting Kang and
following through with the rest of his
plan however returning back to Egypt to
impersonate Rama Tut had its drawbacks
as ravona wants nothing of him even
though he allows her to be free every
plan has its cons because just like the
Rama taught before had fled the
Fantastic Four the same happens for
Richards unable to defeat them he
Retreats into the time stream far into a
war-torn future a thousand years after
the Terminators took over and his own
31st Century Origins just as time time
is a tricky tricky [__] it shows her
ugly face once again as Richards sees
ravona leading a resistance Against the
Machines and other evil forces in this
otherwise dystopian world he has found
himself in even though this is a comic
it's it's just Pages you just know
Johnny Lee's looking for love started to
play when he saw rivona's face
and all the wrong places Richards now
finds himself in 4086 CE with ravona and
begins to have a Ramona Flowers and
Matthew patel-esque relationship as the
two scrap destroy and kill the opposing
forces war and violence is their love in
this world however as Richards thinks
he's starting to crack rivona's hardened
exterior and show his real feelings she
shoots him down saying his knowledge of
history and time may have worked on a
lesser woman than she but this ravona
belongs to herself The One and Only Rule
of Kang rang in his mind once again do
not love Richards finally took this to
heart and his love would be Conquest he
conquered and defeated many of the
factions in this dystopia becoming
intoxicated with the feeling of Victory
it then clicked for him he finally felt
like he was in control of his own
destiny now no other time in his life
did he feel this this was something
different he was never going to let it
go Richards find some old Tech he had
only heard about from the tales of the
other Kang and crafts himself the neuro
kinetic armor Kang wore all of those
years ago Richards was now Kang with his
new armor fixed up time ship Richards
now Kang set out to conquer all of time
in space from King Arthur to skrulls to
even other variants of himself his
Conquest led him to the final Kingdom of
Earth the only free one and to his
surprise princess rivona was its ruler
the same he had met long before his
years of tyranny and Conquest love once
again flashed in his mind as he calls
off his attack and basically Great
Gatsby's it by longingly staring at her
kingdom from afar watching waiting come
is or rating
he sees the only way to win her love is
to let her kingdom be free he calls off
his attack and instead once again
becomes a hero however balltog and
Kang's previous General storm ravonus
Kingdom killing her and soon Kang
realizes he can never Escape it Kang was
his prison all of this time and he had
literally constructed the bars around
himself but Kang sees something his
mentor didn't constructing an omni
viewer to view all of time as he
promises ravona to be his final Conquest
now thinking about it this all feels
very cloud atlas-like with different
incarnations of the same characters
popping up in the past present future
Kang now creates chronopolis and in
doing so has ravona reborn throughout
time and space thousands of times
thinking at least one of them will you
know maybe love King back desperate if
you ask me but uh this all feels like
Guy Pierces the time machine with him
going back and forth in time only to
realize as he can never be with his
lover because of countless reasons and
we see here that there's rivonas
rejecting him dying before he arrives
defeating him and hundreds of other
reasons like the TVA one just whooping
his ass Kang finds one more ravona in a
distant future that survives but because
of the machines that have built her she
knows all of time and what Kang was
doing from the very beginning in doing
so she saves all of her other selves
destroying chronopolis and sending Kang
floating aimlessly Through Time Kang
ends up where all of this started 10
minutes before the young Richards
himself is asked to join him on the
cosmic time stream Richards was
responsible for his own fate all of
those thousands of years ago I
absolutely love this all of the
destruction was his own fault from the
beginning angle that they spun on this
the events of the young Richard play out
the same way that we had kind of seen
prior leading to the asteroid strike 65
million years ago however the Elder Kang
knew of Richard's plan because well that
was him and instead had a spare suit at
the ready moments before the asteroid
hits Kang boards his time vessel and
instead just exists in space and time a
man who had everything he ever wanted
but with a broken heart a love that he
could never have a love he experienced
at a young age but then was lost to time
and it's well pun intended heartbreaking
to see that Elder Kang was the young
Richards all along and that he knew how
everything would play out the pain that
love would bring them but he couldn't
stop his younger self from enjoying the
thrill of love but there is the downfall
that comes after it ravona was his true
one love honestly the person who created
and shaped him but this looping story
that just goes on and on and on much
like the prison he mentions throughout
he's never really in control while also
being in control that's why the final
words are never ever love it's such a
bitter sweet and brutal ending to his
story a hero a villain a king that just
wanted to hang with ravona but instead
ended up in a love coma now it could
potentially see Quantum Mania laying the
groundwork for this Kang origin story
and how it could play into the larger
MCU with Avengers Kang Dynasty the
quantum Realms chronopolis is just a
variation on the chronopolis that is
featured here and essentially the Kang
Prime finally arrived here after the
whole time story Adventure I wouldn't be
surprised if rivona is brought into this
in some capacity being implemented at
the TVA by Kang himself and also would
be a cheeky wink wink nod to the TVA
outfitted rivona in this comic run in
affection of sorts maybe not the whole
love or death approach to the two's
relationship also the idea of the three
time Keepers being a Boris ramatut and
Scarlet Centurion I mean come on this
story would allow for a whole Bevy of
MCU heroes from different Generations
timelines multiverses to pop up and have
a swing at the big guy which is the big
Rumor for Secret Wars and the whole idea
of his creation was his destruction and
he is solely responsible would be a hell
of a story a cool M night
shyamalan-esque holy [__] reveal at the
end of things it's a badass origin so
expect at least some influences from
this but obviously I'd love to hear what
you think of the different Kang Origins
here and would this make for a great
driver for The Avengers Kang Dynasty and
I'll let you know we're currently
running a competition giving away three
Rocky IV box sets on the 15th of March
and all you got to do to get a chance of
winning this is like this video
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment for Kang anything about Kang
down below we pick the comments at
random at the end of every single month
and the winners of last month are on
screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our other Kang
content with our quantumania breakdown
and post-credits scenes explainer but
with all of that out of the way thank
you for your constant support I've been
Jared I'll see in the next one take care
and peace